The day just ended for someone.
And the day just started for somebody.
In empty streets I walked about
Confessing my boredom out loud.
I wanna keep feeling it.
But you won't forget about this
Knock Three Times, before requesting.
I wanna keep touching it.
Trouble's no longer a thing
When a future
You just waved to me.
I wanna keep feeling it.
But you won't forget about this
Knock Three Times, before requesting.
I wanna keep touching it.
Trouble's no longer a thing
When a future
You just waved to me.
A Holiday of Two Hours
HUNG! WHY DIDN'T YOU PICK UP MY PHONE?
Have the guests arrived?
You still have 2 hours.
That's hardly enough time to make food!
Take-outs would be fine!
That won't show our sincerity.
Help me delay the guests.
QUIET! What's going on so early in the morning?
Aak! I'm out of time! You gotta help me!
Cut the potatoes like this.
Make a cross cut on the tomatoes, then boil and peel them.
I might cut my hands.
Bend the fish mint like this, and throw away those that are too old.
Ugh, the smell!
This looks really hard.
I'll help clear your customer orders for next month!
This is starting to look a lot easier.
It is easy, Aak! I know you can do it!
Jaye, I need to order two fins from you. The ones with little spines.
Step 1. Get rid of the smell.
Aak.
Come here, Aak. I need to tell you something.
Sure!
No, not here. We ought to go there.
Are we there yet?
No.
We're close.
Are we there yet?
Almost there.
Jaye
Where's my seafood?
AAAH? Huh? I'm closing shop.
I thought you placed an order.
Just give me the two fins now.
We're out of fins.
But we just caught a crab. Interested?
Forget it! I gotta run!
You have news on that guy?
The choice is yours. Do you want risk this or not?
Are we there yet?
We're here!
I think we've been here before!
Uh, well, modern city buildings look pretty much alike, right?
(Waai Fu)
(Everybody, sorry for the wait.)
What's this strange smell?
Something smells.
(Oh darling,)
(don't you know? Don't you know life's so sweet?)
(I wonder what you're dream-ing of.)
(And for tomorrow, I'll greet your gaze)
(And then I'll say hello.)
(You'll smile at me too.)
MY ANTIQUES! MY ART COLLECTION!
MY UTENSILS! MY INGREDIENTS!
( Life is so sweet.)
I guess we lost all our data.
We're fine. I made a backup copy online.
(Rainbows in the sky we see,)
(Comets in the galaxy.)
We're missing nothing.
Sorry.
(Comets in the galaxy.)
We'll have to start working hard tomorrow to repair the detective office.
(Then this world starts getting warm)
(Coz you're its most brilliant star.)
Hi. Pizza for Miss Waai Fu?
(I tell ya, don't give up, and don't be sad today,)
Yes. Thanks a lot.
Jaye, you had dinner yet?
(I tell ya, don't give up, and don't be sad today,)
(Coz we are dreamers.)
No.
(You can change, get up and sing this song,)
Then let's eat together!
(Then build the future world.)
(Oh Darling)
(Don't you know? Don't you know life's so sweet?)
(I wonder what you're dream-ing of.)
(And for tomorrow, I'll greet your gaze)
(And then I'll say hello.)
(Yes darling)
(Don't you know? Don't you know?)
(Lo and behold, you got a date with a miracle.)
Honorable Waai Fu, you're a truly powerful warrior!
(In a world pristine, untouched and clean,)
Be our new boss!
(Love still waits for you.)
We shall be the Tiger Mafia from now on!
(It's gentle and true,)
(Life is so sweet.)
MY UTENSILS!
MY ANTIQUES!
No! No! No! No!
Definitely no!
A request from a former Cat Mafia member:
Make Waai Fu the BOSS of our TIGER MAFIA.
REJECTED
Reason for rejection: Not interested. Go boss yourself.